Robin you have an extensive background
and theatre production you know writing
stage plays if someone came to you who's
also looking to make the transition from
from theatre productions to filmmaking
you know what would you want them to
know what would you say to them oh well
let me think here the main thing here is
to you know if you're writing for stage
you know in my opinion it's a you know
that's all about telling a story with
words it's not my opinion it's a fact
you know and in the film it's your
showing you can show the story you know
so much you know and often people are
simple just play rides will be too wordy
with a film you know so make sure that
you and it was really difficult for me
to grasp this but I finally did to
realize that you can tell a story just
you know without saying as much as you
know you don't have to say a lot you
know you still have dialogue and but not
as much you know you have to really get
break out of it you know realize every
you don't have to say everything that's
going on in a play everything has to be
spoken about everything you know and
just make a couple films just you know
what you're at home for free you know
with your iPhone whatever just practice
telling stories and not saying
everything and just make sure you do
that because if you shoot a play a film
about a play it's boring okay then I
used to fight that I used to say no no
no it's such a cool play but if you
watch it on camera it's it's hard to
keep your attention you know but if you
you know so make sure you keep in mind
that we're dealing with the short
attention span society more now than
ever and we need to as a playwright
you're going to shoot a film take the
words out of the mouth of the actors and
put it in a deal with the camera
you know that the camera tell the story
and that the actors speak when they need
to but not always about every little
thing you know we're going over here we
don't need to say that just go over
there and so you know your approach or
of writing a stage play compared to
writing a screenplay and is a totally
different starting point is it totally
different mindset yeah yeah yeah it has
to be you know um I'm really it I just
wrote an actionscript action drama and
as the first time I ever wrote anything
like that and action is easier to write
because you can write fill a page with
the car chase you know but writing about
the two characters on a stage talking
and you know making that interesting
that that's a lot of hard work you know
and so they're two totally different
approaches I gotta tell you
screenwriting is easier I think than
playwriting because there's so much more
to work with you know so much more
available to you to put on the page on a
stage all you can say is you know what
the two characters are saying to one
another and stage direction and that's
it Phil 50 pages 280 pages or whatever
you're doing is a full-length play
whatever you doing with just people
talking and hold people's attention and
I did that in New York and that was hard
if you hold people's attention for one
hour with words you're getting somewhere
you